Diya is looking to buy a plot
of land to build her home on.
She finally narrows
her search to two plots
that both have good locations.
The plot at 314159 Apple
Lane has a width of 30 meters
and a length of 40 meters.
The plot at 11235 Fibonacci
Drive has a width of 50 meters
and a length of 20 meters.
They are each being
sold for $36,000.
Which one is a better deal?
So they're the same
price, and they're
in comparable neighborhoods.
So really, the better
deal is the one
that actually gets me more area.
So I encourage you to pause
the video and think about,
which one of these am
I getting more land
for the same amount of money?
Well, to think about how
much land I'm getting,
I'm really thinking
about, how much space
is that plot taking up?
Or I'm really
thinking about, what
is the area of each
of these plots?
And we've already
figured out that you
can calculate the
area of a rectangle
by multiplying its
length times its width.
So the area of Apple Lane is 40
meters times 30 meters, which
is equal to-- 40 times 3 is 120.
40 times 30 is 1,200.
And then it's
meters times meters.
Or you can view this as square
meters, 1,200 square meters.
Now let's think
about what the area
of the plot at
Fibonacci Drive is.
So its length is 20.
Its width is 50.
So here the area is 20
meters times 50 meters, which
is equal to-- 20 times 5 is 100.
20 times 50 is
1,000 square meters.
So it's pretty clear when
you calculate the area
that Apple Lane, you're getting
more square meters than you
would get at Fibonacci Drive.
And literally, when we say
1,200 square meters, that
means if you were to
put a 1 meter by 1
meter square here--
so a really small one
like that-- then you
could fit 1,200 of these
on this plot of land, while you
could only fit 1,000 of them
on this plot of land-- of these
1 meter by 1 meter squares.
So we have a larger area, same
neighborhood or comparable
neighborhood for the same price.
I would go with Apple Lane
being the better deal.